today on the matt wall show the arizona
department of education is concerned
that our babies
might be racist so what can we do about
our racist babies we'll talk about that
today also five headlines including
the creepiest covid psa you'll ever see
plus joe biden lashing out at people who
are fed up with
masks and lockdowns and andrew cuomo
addresses the sexual harassment scandal
while mostly ignoring the real scandal
and in our daily cancellation we'll
discuss the host of the bachelor who
continues to debase himself in
increasingly embarrassing ways in the
hopes of earning forgiveness
from the cancel mob but that never works
we'll talk about that and much more
today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
for the latest now in racialized
brainwashing returned to
arizona where the arizona department of
education has developed an equity
toolkit
which contains lots of surprising
information but nothing more surprising
than this according to
the arizona department of ed babies are
racist
journalist chris ruffo has the material
which begins with a chart
detailing uh the course of a young
child's life from birth to about six
years old
and at the top it tells us that quote
they're not too young to talk about race
continuing it says young children notice
and think about race
adults often worry that talking about
race will encourage racial bias in
children but the opposite is true
silence about race reinforces racism by
letting children draw their own
conclusions based on what they see
now wait let's stop right there for a
moment because uh so you're saying we're
not supposed to let children draw their
own conclusions
really but aren't these the same people
who tell us that we have to respect the
child's self-determined gender
identity at the age of three so we
should let a three-year-old
a three-year-old boy we should let him
draw his own conclusions about whether
or not he's actually a boy
but he can't draw his own conclusions
about race
okay got it all right back to the fact
sheet it says uh well not a fact sheet
but it is a sheet anyway
and it goes on it says teachers and
families can play a powerful role in
helping children of all ages develop
positive attitudes about race and
diversity
and skills to promote a more just future
but only if we talk about it first
and from there we follow the child over
the course of his young racist life
first we're told uh quote at birth
babies look equally at faces of all
races
at three months babies look more at
faces that match the race of their
caregivers
my god those shameless bigots see i
always suspected this you know
when my youngest was a newborn and she
would cry for mommy
and i would always say to her you only
want mommy because she's white
i know you're game i'm on to you see
it's very important to call out the nazi
babies
when you see them even if it's your own
child and i know it could be a difficult
thing
it could be a difficult thing to look at
your three-month three-month-old and
realize
that she is a nazi but this is something
that you have to do as a parent
anyway then it says children as young as
two years old
use race to reason about people's
behaviors
then by 30 months most children use race
to choose playmates
side note my primary problem here is
that they said 30 months
like i can't stand it when people
identify their kids ages by months
because it forces me to do math which i
don't want to have to do
so when someone says like yes my child
is 87 and a half months old
continuing it says expressions of racial
prejudice often peak at ages four and
five so this is like when it
when someone is the most racist is is is
at four
and then uh it says by five black and
latinx children
in research settings show no preference
towards their own groups compared to
white
white children at this age remain
strongly biased in favor of whiteness
well yeah that i just flat out don't
believe it's certainly exactly the
result that the researchers hoped to
find
and that's why i don't believe it
clearly bogus but we'll keep going
it says by by kindergarten children show
many of the same racial attitudes that
adults in our culture hold
they have already learned to associate
some groups with higher status than
others
and finally explicit conversations with
five to seven-year-olds about
interracial friendships
can dramatically improve their racial
attitudes in as little as a single week
okay let's break this down there are
three problems here well there's a lot
more than three but we only have a few
minutes for this segment so let's focus
on three
first contrary to what has become
popular belief at least popular belief
among people who work for the school
system
it is not actually the school system's
job to combat racism or to make children
more
racially and morally enlightened or
anything like that
its job is to educate children in the
subjects that parents send their
children to school for
math history science etc abcs and 123s
that's basically it
now you might argue that it's not really
possible in practice to separate
factual and moral education you might
say that all
education will inherently have the goal
of making children into better people
that is better according to the
standards and values of the educator
so i'm sympathetic to that view in fact
i agree with it
that's just another reason to get your
kids the hell out of the public school
system
as i'm always urging everybody
moral formation is always a part of
education
we may say that in the case of the
public school system it shouldn't be
that's not the system's job it's not
what you send your children there for
that's all true but the two will not be
separated and never have been separated
so if you don't want your child to be
morally formed or malformed
by the system you have to extract your
child
from that system second point on the
issue of racist babies
is it true that children show a
preference for their own race
yeah probably to some extent sure
it's probably true true that even very
young children do
three months old they're told we're told
now
there really isn't any way to know what
a three-month-old is thinking
but we have no idea about the inner life
of a three-month-old
we were all three months old at one time
some of us act like we still are
but none of us can remember what that's
like so it's a strange thing that
something we all experienced
is so mysterious to us but that's that's
what it means to be human that's part of
the human condition
yet to the extent that we can develop
some ideas about
how babies think and what they think
it's probably true that they have quote
racial preferences
why well because they're going to
gravitate towards people
who look like their own families
it's that simple a baby when she first
starts saying mama and dada
she's likely to say it to every woman
who looks vaguely like her mama and
every man who looks vaguely like her
dada
she's drawing connections and
correlations she's noticing similarities
noticing patterns
she doesn't understand them she doesn't
assign moral
value to anything but she notices them
this is normal this is fine this is
healthy there's no problem here it's not
racism
i can't believe i have to explain this
but it's not racism
yeah i i shouldn't need to explain that
your three-month-old is
has a preference for mommy and women who
look like mommy
and that it's not because she's racist
like i shouldn't have to explain that
but apparently i do
see racism is the belief that certain
races are inferior
racism is for example how blm activists
treat white people that's racism
if you treat another race with animosity
hatred vengeance
that's racism little kids don't have any
of that
they just might feel most comfortable
feel safest around people who look
the most like mama and dada
not only is that not racist but it's
actually good it's good that a child has
a special connection with his
tribe and his tribe for him is his
family
this is biologically ingrained it's
it's supposed to be that way it should
be that way
when a child gets scared or nervous
around a stranger she runs and hugs
daddy's leg hides behind him
she wants to be closer to the person she
knows
she feels safe around there's no reason
to
actively deprogram this instinct
children will kind of grow out of it
naturally and that's and that's fine too
but of course the left can never let a
child just grow
naturally anymore they cannot let that
happen
and that brings us to the third point
we're told to talk
with our children about race and if we
don't talk about race
then they'll be racist that's the claim
but i think the opposite is the case in
fact
i prefer the advice given by morgan
freeman years ago i don't know if you
maybe you've heard this is a famous clip
but if you haven't
and i don't know if he would still say
this now in our uber woke era
but 15 or 20 years ago when asked about
this subject
here's what he said slack history month
you find ridiculous why
you're going to relegate my history to a
month oh come on what do you do with
yours
which month is white history month
come on tell me well
i'm jewish okay which month is jewish
history month
uh there isn't one oh oh
why not yeah do you want one no no no no
i i don't either i don't want a black
history month
black history is american history how
are we going to get rid of racism
unstoppable talking about it
i'm going to stop calling you a white
man
yeah i'm going to ask you to stop
calling me
a black man i know you as mike wallace
you know me as morgan freeman
okay stop talking about it there's more
wisdom in that 55 second clip of a
hollywood actor than all of the critical
race theory toolkits and seminars that
have ever been devised
i can say anecdotally this was my
experience as a child
i noticed when someone was a different
race um if somebody looked different i
noticed that obviously i wondered about
it
i may have i may have asked questions
like why do they look different the
kinds of questions
that all kids have the questions that my
kids have had
totally normal but it never occurred to
me as a child to make a big
thing out of it i didn't draw any
sweeping conclusions based on the fact
that somebody looked different
as a kid you play with whoever else
happens to be on the playground what is
their race matter
that's the great thing about kids i mean
mine will make a new best friend with
anyone some random child they meet in
the food court at the zoo
whoever as children learn to branch out
a little bit
and talk to and befriend people outside
of their family units they embark on
that quest
without baggage they don't have all this
baggage they just go out there and kids
are kids and
and and all of that the baggage is added
later
by garbage like this by critical race
theorists and
other assorted race hustlers see kids
don't naturally see race as a big deal
they see race course everybody does
they don't see it as a big deal you have
to make it a big deal
that's why the left has to work so hard
to convince them to see it as a big deal
that's why they walk up and they say oh
i see you too a black and a white child
are getting along well
let me tell you about the legacy of
slavery and the evils of systemic racism
and they walk away satisfied that they
have just created racial animosity
and suspicion where it hadn't previously
existed
they say the goal is to defeat racism
but it's exactly the opposite they are
brainwashing kids
into racism they are introducing it
inculcating it
planting the seeds and watching it grow
and we all have to reap what they have
sowed
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
before we get to five headlines i want
to tell you about a podcast that you
should check out it's called the true
underdog podcast
you know raised in a trailer park with
no clear path to success kicked out of
high school multiple times faced with
becoming a father in his teens
jason waller is the definition of a true
underdog that's what we love in this
country
we love underdog stories after hearing
the words no or you can't too many times
he unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies with his most
recent venture power home solar
skyrocketing on a path to becoming a
billion dollar enterprise
so you could join the true underdog
podcast as waller a four-time
entrepreneur of the year
uh shares motivational tips inspiring
stories
business building lessons from the
ground up he shares his life experiences
and that of his high profile guests to
help others better themselves you know
the mistakes that they've had the
triumphs all of that you're going to
learn about
as waller will tell you there's no
elevator to success that climb can only
happen one step at a time
let every true underdog podcast be that
step that elevates you
scared money won't make money that's why
you have to learn from the true underdog
podcast learn about failure learn about
entrepreneurship learn about never
quitting or making excuses it's real
it's raw it's motivational
so check true underdog podcast at
trueunderdog.com or anywhere you get
your podcasts
i just saw this this is um this is news
about pope francis
uh he apparently has a book he just
released a book this is the report
anyway reportedly
he released a book in which he says he
warns
that there might be a second great flood
uh because of climate change
you know and it does kind of remind me
of
genesis 9 11 we all remember that verse
it says i establish my covenant with you
never again will all life be destroyed
by the waters of a flood
never again will there be a flood to
destroy the earth unless you start
driving suvs in which case the deal is
off folks
um so that's right there in the bible
and you know
pope francis yet again staying true to
scripture
and that's why we all love pope francis
so much
all right let's go to number one here
joe biden um
has some words for people who don't want
to stay
locked down and in masks anymore how
dare you
if after a year you're a little fed up
and you want to live a normal life how
dare you
uh this is what joe biden thinks of your
questions to texas in mississippi
texas
i hope everybody's realized by now these
masks make a difference
we are on the cusp of being able to
fundamentally
change the nature of this disease
because the way in which we're able to
get
vaccines in people's arms we've been
able to move that all the way up to the
end of may to have enough for every
american
to get every adult american to get a
shot
and the last the last thing we need is
neanderthal thinking that
in the meantime everything's fine take
off your mask
forget it it still matters i carry a
card
i don't have it i put it on my desk as
of
last as of yesterday we lost 511
874 americans we're gonna lose thousands
more
this will not occur we'll not have
everybody vaccinated so sometime in the
summer we have the vaccine to do it
getting a shot in someone's arm and
getting a second shot
you're gonna take time and it's critical
critical critical critical that they
follow
the science wash your hands
hot water do it frequently wear
a mask and stay socially distanced
and i know you all know that i wish the
heck
some of our elected officials knew it
follow neanderthal thinking follow the
science
so what's what's the science what what
science tells us
that joe biden who's wearing a mask in
that clip
you know we can't even understand what
he's saying it's already it's already
difficult enough to understand what this
guy is saying and now he's muzzled
himself i can't even hear him
um so what's the science that that
supports him wearing a mask
he's fully inoculated he gets tested
every day so he's tested he's fully
vaccinated why is he wearing it
what's what's the reason for him to wear
one what's the scientific reason for him
to wear one
and he's socially he's fully vaccinated
tested and
socially distanced from everybody else
in the home and he's still wearing a
mask
there's no science behind that that's
performance it's performative
it's for show i mean it is it simply is
there's no denying that
now you we we can argue about masks in
general and everything but
in joe biden's case in the case a lot of
these other elected officials
they're vaccinated they're tested
they know they don't have it
and uh yet they're wearing a mask anyway
definitely performance
is that what you want from your elected
officials
turning this into a performance which it
has been for so long
um speaking of performance number two
here the the la unified school district
put out a psa
that is straight out of some kind of
dystopian nightmare
um and we'll we'll watch a little bit of
this but this is
a lot of times when i see this kind of
thing i think like
imagine if it was uh a year ago
or a year and a half ago and you could
look into a crystal ball to see right
now just get a quick snapshot of right
now with no context
so many things that you you see you
would be totally perplexed by
and you would think do we really yeah
you you think okay i knew we were headed
towards
toward a dystopian future but it really
happened that quickly
well this is one of those things if you
saw that without context even seeing it
now it's
it's very disturbing and creepy but uh
here it is
there's never been anything like this
virus in our lifetime
often it's hard to see the effects it's
having on our children
has this conversation taken place in
your home
mom i'm scared about going back to
school i don't want to get sick
and i don't want to get you and dad sick
our scientists tell us there are three
things we must do to stay
safe wear masks make sure we social
distance
and wash our hands and now your school
with the help of microsoft corporation
has created another introducing daily
pass
your exclusive ticket for safely going
back to school
each week you can schedule your free
on-campus coded test
the results are displayed in your daily
pass and if you choose to take your test
off campus
you can post the results in your daily
pass and the moment vaccinations are
available
you'll simply be able to schedule yours
through your daily pass
but the real magic is your daily health
check just answer a few simple health
questions every day
and like magic your entrance ticket
appears
[Music]
welcome back okay
[Music]
all right so there
there you see it uh the
the animation the happy music
uh with our with friends with help from
our friends at microsoft all of that
is supposed to make it not as creepy but
it makes it all the more
creepy makes it so much creepier
where you get your kids smartphone app
daily
uh pass answer some you know keeping
track of
vaccinations and everything answer
health questions and then and then you
get you get entered into school
i think this should be obvious by now
this stuff is not going away
is not going away this is permanent
um in many parts of the country this
will be permanent
in california in los angeles that's
permanent that's not going away
daily health pass i guarantee you 10
years from now they're still going to
have it's going to be
worse it's going to be more intrusive
but they're still going to have a daily
health pass
this is this from the perspective of our
overlords this is a great innovation
gives them more access to your kids more
information about your kids
more better way to keep keep tabs on
them
um tells them more about your kids
perfect that's exactly what the system
wants the
the public school system that's not
going away that's staying with us
all right number three andrew cuomo um
embroiled in his uh scandal
now when i say embroiled in the scandal
there remember
again as we've been talking about there
are two scandals here
uh one scandal that that where he is
responsible for the deaths
of thousands of of of people in nursing
homes
and another scandal where he made
inappropriate comments to women at the
work
in the workplace and
all of the if when you're looking at the
media all the headlines all the
condemnation
from the media from politicians fellow
democrats i mean they're all lining up
to condemn cuomo
but every time you hear any of those
people media politicians
referring to andrew cuomo's scandal they
will always be referring to
the inappropriate comments not the fact
that he killed all those people
and when he was finally forced to give a
press conference and address and give
the tearful apology it was again for the
inappropriate comments and not the fact
that all those people are dead because
of decisions that he made
so here is andrew cuomo on the much much
less serious scandal here's what he has
to say
i fully support a woman's
right to come forward and i think
it should be encouraged in every
way
i now understand that i
acted in a way that made people
feel uncomfortable
it was unintentional and i
truly and deeply apologize for it
i feel awful about
it and frankly
i am embarrassed by it
and that's not easy to say but that's
the truth
but this is what i want you to know and
i want you to know this from me
directly i never
touched anyone inappropriately
i never touched anyone inappropriately
well he's embarrassed it's hard for him
to talk about
very difficult for him poor andrew cuomo
but he supports a woman's
right to come forward
there's that shift to the goal post from
believe all women so i support a woman's
right to come forward of course you do
everybody
is does anyone not support a woman's
right to come forward
is there has is that a point of view
that anyone has expressed at all
does that exist is there an anti-coming
forward position anywhere
that's is anyone saying no you know what
i don't think women have the right
at all i don't think they have the right
to come forward with they feel that
something inappropriate's happened they
don't have the right that's that's my
is anyone saying that no yes of course
you support that right of course these
guys
in this situation they always have to
pretend um
that they're grateful that that women
have come forward against them i'm i'm
grateful that they've come out and
said all these things if what if you are
saying
that their claims are either untrue
or that they have wildly misinterpreted
your actions
um then why would you be grateful
they're saying it
i think it should be encouraged i think
women should be encouraged to come out
and defame me
i think i should do it more often i
couldn't be happier i could not be
happier to be slandered and defamed in
this way
i i think it's just wonderful i
encourage more women to do it in fact
so he's trying to strike a balancing act
there that's impossible to strike but um
again it goes back to this really
doesn't matter compared to um
the real scandal that this is like
and i i i you know when i've when i've
talked about this i've heard from a lot
of people that have said
well they're both bad you know sexual
harassment killing lots of elderly
people with with
the the nursing home policy both bad we
should condemn them both
but that is there is such a wide gap
between these two offenses
that it is like saying um
yeah you know ted bundy was uh was uh uh
or you know john wayne gacy was a was a
serial killer
but he also stole a guy's parking lot at
walmart
and and both of those things are bad
both of those are bad
and they should both we should condemn
them both we need to have a conversation
about both of those things
because they're both bad yeah they are
both bad
but there's really not to put them in
the same sentence to put them in the
same category to lump them all together
under the same
umbrella um is
absurd and insane
so the fact that this is what's going to
take him down or at least even if it
doesn't take him down that this is the
thing we're talking about is
ridiculous but it's uh we know for the
democrats
it's a pretty clever um strategy it's an
obvious strategy
where they've got this very serious
scandal
involving thousands of of people lost
their lives
um and it's due to a policy that was not
just in new york this implicates other
democrat governors too and so from the
democrat party perspective
we cannot talk about that these are
policies
they supported that were adopted by
several
democrat governors prominent ones too
um can't talk about that so let's give
the public another scandal instead
let's give them a scandal that doesn't
matter that cuomo can easily survive and
even if he does and at least he's not
going to take every everyone down with
him
uh and so we'll go with the sexual
harassment thing again instead
yeah i that that is clearly the strategy
it's a brilliant strategy
it me in in an evil way but it's it's
quite brilliant
and it's working even many conservatives
from what i've noticed have
changed they have gone along with this
change of subject
and now when they when when they're
condemning andrew cuomo it's about the
sexual harassment stuff and not the dead
people
all right number four the new york post
has this um
a it says a black florida school
school resource officer was fired after
he was caught on his body camera using
the n-word multiple times
delvin white an officer at middleton
high school was dismissed tuesday for
violations of policy
that prohibit discrimination
discriminatory conduct
the officer used the racial slur while
on the phone and driving home from an
off-duty assignment on november 13th
he repeated it again while on the phone
with his wife
footage also captured white saying the
n-word twice while arresting someone for
trespassing on november 30th
white told his supervisors that he
didn't intend for the word to be
derogatory during the arrest
instead he claimed he was using it as
quote commonly used in today's society
as a means of shared cultural and
culture and experiences among the
african-american community
but he lost his job anyway for saying it
now
this is one of those difficult things
for opponents of cancel culture and all
of this it's like
talk about difficult balancing acts
because on
on one hand it's completely ridiculous
that this man lost his job for that
totally absurd obviously he doesn't
deserve to lose his job for that
on the other hand uh we know that if he
was a white police officer
saying the same things he would
absolutely lose his job and there would
be
no stopping that from happening
so this is a case where it's a it's a
ridiculous standard
but it's being applied equally in this
case
and i am a fan so i'm not a fan of
cancel culture i'm not a fan of people
getting fired for dumb reasons
i am a fan of consistency and equal
standards
so that's that's i you know
that's that's that's the tough thing you
don't you don't exactly know how to how
to balance it but uh
that's an interesting case number five
finally a report from a local journalist
in
north carolina joe bruno who says if you
smoke or have previously smoked at least
100 cigarettes
you'll qualify for a cova 19 vaccine in
north carolina starting on march
24th if you smoked 100 cigarettes you
get to
you get to move up in line for the
vaccine
so we're going to reward not only not
only are we rewarding you
for unhealthy destructive behavior
but it's it is a an incentive
like basically if you if you've smoked
no cigarettes in your life
you have between now and march 24th to
smoke 100.
that's what is that that's how many
cigarettes in a pack 20
that's five packs can you do five packs
in about a month
probably could so go out and
if you were thinking about becoming a
smoker now's the time
see if you can squeeze 100 in
[Music]
what what a ridiculous policy
not to mention now i i know the the
justification for it will be that
smokers are a high-risk category
and so we want to get him vaccinated but
a hundred cigarettes in your whole life
i've probably smoked hundred cigarettes
in my life and i'm not a smoker at all
just casually you know through the years
maybe not a hundred but i've gotten up
there
so even if you smoke if you've smoked
100 cigarettes in your life that doesn't
actually make you
a high-risk category doesn't make you a
smoker at all in fact
so shouldn't it be something like if you
smoke a pack a day or if you've smoked a
pack a day for the last
however many years now you're a high
risk risk category
[Music]
or how about we just don't do this at
all if you have lung disease
smoker or not you're a high risk
category category
you move up in line maybe that should be
the policy
but i think that probably simply makes
too much sense and so we can't do that
let's move on now to reading the youtube
comments
this is from ethan holliday says matt
walsh john cena and keanu reeves
would make a great three dads together
i gotta tell you ethan i do not know how
to take that
thanks i guess i'm not sure um
joseph pennell says i understand your
frustration matt i really enjoy how you
discussed your topics it'd be really
cool to hear you talk more about major
issues outside of our country in china
as well
you're very informative and to the point
i feel you'd be the best source of
information
i'm not the best source of information
for
for foreign policy issues outside of the
country
uh that's that's not where my focus is i
don't think i'm probably the best source
of information for anything
but uh certainly not for those issues so
i would uh go elsewhere for that yomonk
says hey matt
do you pronoun do you uh pronounce
people's names wrong
on purpose example kamela harris
alexandra ocasio-cortez
jen pasaki pronounce their names wrong i
don't know what you're talking about
ali boo says i am keeping two meter
distances it's the best thing that's
ever happened to me
i hate people crowding my space and
touching my body of course i'm looking
forward to crowded places ie
gigs etc when you can be crowded by
choice but generally speaking
back off this is the thing i mean i even
said at the very beginning of the the
pandemic this was the common joke among
antisocial people
where we all said oh we'll do great in
the lockdowns because we're antisocial
anyway
we don't want to be around anybody
anyway so who cares uh so i i
i sort of understand your feeling but
even i
as a thoroughly antisocial person um i
am
i am very much looking forward to
a normal existence where there are
people around
that's why i talk about the masks
one thing that i didn't expect early on
to be so
unsettled by is is simply going out in
public and never seeing anybody else's
face i didn't think that was something i
really appreciated before
i never really thought of it as if i'm
going to walmart that it's so great to
see a stranger's face i never thought of
it that way
but you go a year and you never do and
you realize this is a
this is a one basic facet of human
existence that's been taken away
and it does matter it seems like a small
thing but it actually matters
and it matters even more to our kids
who never see anybody's face outside of
the house
and finally tea leaf says matt is it
possible to have a girlfriend that
doesn't agree with your politics
uh i would say no i mean there are
people who have done it
but if you're if you're going into this
thing like if you're already in
especially if you're married to someone
and you find that you're differing on on
political issues well
you're in it now and now you gotta you
gotta find a way to work through it
you'll probably find a way
but if if if you're early on
or if you're still looking for someone
there's no reason to embrace that
difficulty
because yeah you might be able to make
it work you probably won't
it's it's not worth the trouble
that doesn't mean you have to agree on
every last single thing
but if you disagree fundamentally on
basic
not even political but i would say more
than political because you could you
could agree ideologically a lot of
things but have political differences
but if you disagree ideologically on a
fundamental level you have different
value systems different priorities
different basic beliefs is it possible
to make that work
yes is it worth the trouble
to go into a relationship knowing that
you're going to have that humongous
hurdle to uh to
navigate no it's not i would say
now a quick word from our friends over
at lifelock if you use a free vpn or
virtual private network for increased
privacy when online you may want to
reconsider because free vpns have been
known to harvest data
and may expose your personal information
this can make you vulnerable to identity
theft it's one of the many things that
uh that you know one of the things
many things you have to worry about
online uh in terms of your data being
exposed it's important to understand how
cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives in an instant a
cyber criminal
could take what's yours your hard earned
money your credit your reputation
uh good thing there's lifelock lifelock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats
so many different things and i said it's
where you have to worry about all these
things but you don't have to worry about
them if you have lifelock because
they are going to surveil everything
stuff like your social security
social security number being for sale on
the dark web things that you might not
be able to see for yourself if they
detect your information
has potentially been compromised they're
going to send you an alert
you have access to a dedicated
restoration specialist if you become a
victim so you've got
defense on the one end and then help on
the other end too gives you all the
coverage that you need
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock identity theft protection
join now
and save up to 25 off your first year by
going to lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walsh to save
25
off and you know we've been telling you
about ben shapiro's new show
uh called debunked and it's important
show because there are so many crazy
leftist theories
and outright lies out there and that's
exactly what ben shapiro
uh is dealing with and debunking in his
new daily news
daily wire series which appropriately is
called debunked every friday
ben exposes popular fallacies reported
by left-wing activists and politicians
with
short mini documentaries that entertain
and keep you informed
so the last episode was about minimum
wage debunking minimum wage
if you haven't seen that yet definitely
worth checking out um
and his next episode he's gonna be
breaking down unions
and that's another thing that you don't
want to miss so go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code debunk to get 25
off your new membership
and you can watch this friday's episode
you can watch the last episode in all
episodes
of debunked you don't want to miss any
of them go sign up now
code debunked for 25 off now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we're going to cancel um the host
of the bachelor or rather former host of
the bachelor chris harrison it may seem
a bit redundant to cancel him after he's
already been thoroughly canceled by the
woke mob
i mean why kick a man when he's down you
might say well because
even when you're down especially when
you're down you should comport yourself
with a little courage and dignity if you
can't do that
you deserve to be doubly canceled so
backing up here for a moment to review
now we followed this story on this show
not because we care about the bachelor
in fact the existence of a show like the
bachelor is one of the many reasons why
i'll be on the first ship to elon musk's
mars colony in the near future but the
reason this story matters is that it so
perfectly captures everything that is
wrong and insane
about cancel culture if you recall one
of the contestants on the show rachel
kirk cannell
became the target of the cancel mob
after someone dug through her past and
discovered that she'd attended an old
south
uh uh party three years ago an old south
themed a um
antebellum themed party three years ago
this generated way more controversy than
it should have generated because it
should have generated exactly zero
controversy
and that's what led the host chris
harrison to sort of defend kirk canel in
an interview with a former bachelorette
named rachel lindsay who is black
in her defense harrison
only made the point that we should have
some grace and forgiveness for this
woman and not try to ruin her life over
some frat party she attended years ago
he went out of his way to stipulate that
he was not defending her choice to go to
the party
so it was the weakest most circumspect
least aggressive defense a person could
possibly offer of anything
and it was enough to get him canceled
next thing you know he's being labeled a
racist he's getting thrown under the bus
by the cast of the show the media the
interviewer
his own girlfriend then he has to step
down from the show all while he
all while he apologizes profusely
groveling sobbing
begging all to no avail
that brings us to this morning when
harrison appeared on good morning
america to continue his apology tour and
to ramp up the groveling by a few more
notches
here's uh here's the report from page
six
i'm an imperfect man i made a mistake
and i own that he told co-anchor michael
strahan on good morning america
i believe that a mistake doesn't reflect
who i am or what i stand for i am
committed
to the progress not just for myself but
for the franchise
antebellum parties are not okay he said
past present future knowing what that
represents is unacceptable
he also again apologized to 35 year old
lindsay as well as the black community
for his words
harrison made it clear that he is not a
victim and said he's committed to making
changes for himself and the abc
franchise going forward
i made a mistake and i own that he said
racism oppression
these are big dynamic problems i i and
they take
serious work i am committed to that work
harrison also said he's been working
with race educator dr eric dyson
who's taught him the idea of counsel not
cancel
as a result harrison said he's taken
full accountability for his actions and
is learning from the black community by
listening
okay a race educator i imagine that a
session with a race educator means
locking yourself in a stockade
and yelling i hate my whiteness while
tomatoes and rotten eggs are thrown in
your face
or maybe that's what they do at the
graduation party after you complete the
course i don't know in any case
harrison is continuing and continuing
and going to increasingly desperate
lengths to
performatively debase himself in hopes
that he'll be forgiven
never mind the fact that he never did
anything wrong in the first place
he has nothing to apologize for except
for the fact that he has ever hosted the
bachelor to begin with
and now for the fact that he's
apologizing in the first place so
come to think of it the only thing in
his life that he shouldn't be
apologizing for
is the one thing that he is apologizing
for the one
good and worthwhile thing he ever did
apprehensively standing up to cancel
culture is now the thing that he
expresses
deep regret over and it doesn't matter
it won't work he will never be accepted
back into polite society
never now i haven't read the punch line
of this whole thing
the final sentence in the page six
article is great it says
following the interview strahan
described his conversation with harrison
as a quote surface response
so there it is michael strahan by the
way
a hall of fame defensive end for the new
york giants
um and a guy who almost certainly has
said
many things in the locker room and while
lined up at the line of scrimmage that
a guy like chris harrison would never
dream of saying
but now michael strahan is so offended
by chris harrison calling for
forgiveness for someone else
that two weeks of tearful apologies
doesn't cut it
it's a surface response what more does
strahan want
what else can harrison do kill himself
i don't say that as a joke i don't joke
about suicide i really mean it the
cancel
mob won't be satisfied until people
start killing themselves over it
and they will by the way if they haven't
already
and this is all the more reason why
people with means
people in the public eye people with
wealth harrison is worth 25 million
dollars
they need to stand up to this madness
because when you grovel when you whimper
when you fall to your knees you are
emboldening the mob
empowering it encouraging it and making
it worse for the next guy who was
canceled
and who may not have the ability that
you have to fight back and withstand it
chris harrison is 50 years old and worth
25 million dollars if he invests that
money well
you know he's got more than enough to
live comfortably
he could tell the canceled mob to kiss
his ass and ride off into the sunset
maybe write a best-selling book down the
line about his experiences make a few
more million
we'd even probably hire him we'd hire
him here at the daily wire probably
we could do our own version of the
bachelor with him who knows
the point is harrison has options he
doesn't have to do what he's doing
and it's not working anyway and it will
never work
but he keeps trying having forfeited his
dignity
there's nowhere else to go but down i
guess and he will keep plunging the
depths of his own disgrace
and that's why he's canceled again
just keep keeps coming more and more
cancellations
until he grows a spine and stands up and
says you know what
i take back all of my apologies i don't
apologize for any of this you people are
crazy get out of my face
if he does that i will rescind my
cancellation i mean the other
cancellations won't be rescinded but at
least that will
and it'll have his dignity back and
that's worth something
may not be worth a salary hosting a
bachelor but it's worth something
but for now he's canceled and that'll
leave it there for us today thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vladowski the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. andrew cuomo
addresses
sexual misconduct allegations biden
promises another year of covid craziness
and dr fauci admits that florida got
some things right
check it out on the michael knowles show